tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay and fight to
save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other like
[Music]
it's my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything just kept
me happening
really broke the universe
besides we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
here
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
hey Miss Kara Barry
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
[Music]
foreign